we hopefully now have a respectable
working knowledge of the sampling
distribution of the sample mean and what
i want to do in this video is explore a
little bit more on how that distribution
changes as we change our sample size n
all write n down right here our sample
size n so just as a bit of review we saw
before we could just start off with any
crazy distribution maybe it looks
something like this
i'll do a discrete distribution
really to model anything at some point
you have to make it discrete it could be
a very granular discrete distribution
but let's say something crazy that looks
like this this is clearly not
a normal distribution but we saw in the
first video if you take let's say sample
size is a four so if you took four
numbers from this distribution four
random numbers where
let's say this is you know the
probability of one two three four five
six seven
eight nine
if you took four numbers at a time and
averaged them let me do that here
if you took four numbers at a time let's
say we take we we use this distribution
to generate four random numbers right
we're very likely to get a nine we're
definitely not going to get any seven or
eights we're definitely not going to get
a four uh we might get a one or two
three is also very likely five is very
likely so we use this function to
essentially generate random numbers for
us and we take samples of four and then
we average them up so let's say our
first average is like you know i don't
know it's it's a nine
it's a five it's another nine
and then it's a 1. so what is that
that's 14 plus 10 24 divided by 4. the
average
for this first trial for this first
sample of 4 is going to be
6 right they add up to 24 divided by 4.
so we would plot it right here our
average was six that time
just like that and we'll just keep doing
it and we've seen in the past
that if you just keep doing this this is
going to start looking something like a
normal distribution so maybe we do it
again the average is six again maybe we
do it again the average is five we do it
again the average is seven we do it
again the average is six and then if you
just do this a ton a ton of times your
distribution might look something that
looks very much like a normal
distribution so if these boxes are
really small so we just do a bunch of
these trials at some point it might look
a lot like a normal distribution
obviously there's some average values it
won't be a perfect normal distribution
because you can never get anything less
than
zero or anything less than a one really
as an average you can't get zero as an
average and you can't get anything more
than 9. so it's going to it's not going
to have infinitely long tails but at
least for the middle part of it a normal
distribution might be a good
approximation
in this video what i want to think about
is what happens is we change
as we change
n so in this case n was 4
n is our sample size every time we do a
trial we took 4 and we took their
average and we plotted it we could have
had n equal 10 we could have taken 10
samples from this from this population
you could say are from this random
variable
average them and then plotted them here
and in the last video we ran the
simulation i'm going to go back to that
simulation a second we saw a couple of
things
and i'll
show it to you a little bit more depth
this time
when n is pretty small it doesn't
approach a normal distribution that well
so when when n is small i mean let's
take the extreme case what happens when
n is equal to one
that little name just means i take one
instance of this random variable and
average it well it's just going to be
that thing so if i just take a bunch of
trials from this thing and plot it over
time what's it going to look like well
it's definitely not going to look like a
normal distribution it's going to look
you're going to have a couple of ones
you're going to have a couple of twos
you're going to have
more threes like that you're going to
have no fours you're going to have a
bunch of fives you're going to have some
sixes that look like that and you're
gonna have a bunch of nines
so there your sampling distribution of
the sample mean for an n of one is going
to look i don't care how many trials you
do it's not going to look like a normal
distribution so the central limit
theorem although i said you know you do
a bunch of trials that look like a
normal distribution it definitely
doesn't work for n equal 1. as n gets
larger though it starts to make sense
that let's say if if we got n equals 2
and i'm all just doing this in my head i
don't know what the actual distributions
would look like but then it still would
be difficult for it to become an exact
normal distribution but then you can get
more instances that you could get more
you know you might get things from all
of the above but you can only get two in
each of your baskets that you're
averaging only get two numbers right so
you're never gonna
let's see i mean for example you're
never gonna get a seven and a half in
your in your in your sampling
distribution of the sample mean for n is
equal to two because it's impossible to
get a seven and it's impossible to get
an eight so you're never going to get
seven as a seven and a half as so maybe
when you plot let me
when you plot it maybe
you know maybe it looks like this but
there'll be a gap at seven and a half
because that's impossible and you know
maybe it looks something like that
so it still won't be a normal
distribution when n is equal to 2. so
there's a couple of
interesting things here so one thing and
i didn't mention this the first time
because i really wanted to get the gut
sense of what the central limit theorem
is
the central limit theorem says as n
approaches really as it approaches
infinity then is when you get the real
normal distribution
normal distribution but in kind of
everyday practice you don't have to get
that much beyond n equals 2. if you get
to n equals 10 or n equals 15 you're
getting very close to a normal
distribution so this converges to a
normal distribution very quickly
distribution
now the other thing is you obviously
want many many trials so this is your
sample size
that is your sample size that's the size
of each of your baskets in the very
first video i did on this i took a
sample as a size of four in the in the
simulation i did the in the last video
we did sample sizes of four and ten and
whatever else this is a sample size of
one so that's our sample size so as that
approaches infinity your your your
actual sampling distribution of the
sample
of the sample mean will approach a
normal distribution
now in order to actually see that normal
distribution
and actually to prove it to yourself you
would have to do this many many remember
the normal distribution happens this is
essentially this is this is kind of the
population or this is the random
variable that tells you all of the
possibilities in real life we we seldom
know all of the possibilities in fact in
real life we seldom know the pure
probability generating function only if
we're kind of writing it or writing a
computer program normally we're doing
samples
and we're trying to estimate things so
normally there's some random variable
and then maybe we'll do a bunch of
we take a bunch of samples we take their
means and we plot them and then we're
going to get some type of normal
distribution let's say we take samples
of 100 and we average them we're going
to get some normal distribution and in
theory as we take as we take those
averages hundreds or thousands of times
our data set is going to
more closely approximate that pure
sampling
distribution
of
the sample
of the sample mean this thing is a real
distribution it's a real distribution
with a real mean its mean it has a pure
mean
its mean
so the mean
of the sample
of the sampling the mean of the sampling
distribution of the sample mean we'll
write it like that
notice i didn't write it as as as just
the x what this is is this is actually
saying
that this is a real population mean this
is a real random variable mean this this
if you looked at every possibility of
all of the samples that you can take
from your original distribution from
some other random original distribution
and you took all of the possibilities
of let's say sample size let's say we're
dealing with the world where sample size
is 10. if you took all of the
combinations of 10 samples from some
original distribution and you average
them out this would be
this would describe that function of
course in reality if you don't know the
original distribution you can't take an
infinite samples from it so you don't
know you won't know every combination
but if you did if you did it with uh you
know if you did it with
a thousand if you did the trial a
thousand times so thousand times you
took 10 samples from some distribution
and took a thousand averages and then
plotted them you're going to get pretty
close you're going to get pretty close
now the next thing i want to touch on is
what happens is n we know as n
approaches infinity it becomes more of a
normal distribution but you know as i
said already n equals 10 is pretty good
and n equals 20 is even better
but we saw something in the last video
that at least i find pretty interesting
let's say you know we start with this
crazy distribution up here really
doesn't matter what distribution we're
starting with we saw in the simulation
that when n is equal let's say n is
equal to 5
our graph after we try you know we take
samples of 5 average them and we do it
10 000 times our graph looks something
like this
it's kind of wide like that and then
when we did n is equal to 10
n is equal to 10 our graph looked a
little bit it was actually a little bit
squeezed in like that a little bit more
so not only was it more normal it you
know that's what the central limit
theorem tells us because we're taking
larger sample sizes but it had a smaller
standard deviation or a smaller variance
right the mean is going to be the same
either case but when our sample size was
larger our standard deviation became
smaller in fact our standard deviation
became smaller than our original
population distribution so let me our
original
probability density function let me show
you that with the simulation
so let me clear everything
and this simulation is as good as any so
the first thing i want to show or this
distribution is as good as any the first
thing i want to show you is that n of 2
is really not that good so and let's
compare an n of 2 to let's say an n of
16.
so when you compare an n of 2 to an n of
you know let's do it once so you get 1 2
trials you average them and then it's
going to do 16
and it's going to plot it down here and
the average is there let's do that 10
000 times
so notice when you took an n of 2 even
though we did it 10 000 times this is
not approaching a normal distribution
you can actually see it in the skew and
kurtosis numbers it has a rightward
positive skew which means it has a
longer tail to the right than to the
left and then it has a negative kurtosis
which means that it's a little bit
it has shorter tails and smaller peaks
than a standard normal distribution
now when n is equal to 16 you do the
same so every time we took 16 samples
from this
from this distribution function up here
and average them and each of these dots
represent an average we did it ten
thousand and one times here notice the
mean is the same in both places but here
all of a sudden our kurtosis is much
smaller and our skew is much smaller so
we are more normal in this in this
situation but even a more interesting
thing is our standard deviation is
smaller right this is more squeezed in
than that is and it's definitely more
squeezed in than our original
distribution now let me do it with two
let me clear everything again i i like
this distribution because it's a it's a
it's it's a it's a very non-normal
distribution it looks like a bimodal
distribution of some kind and let's take
a scenario where i take an n of let's
take two good ends let's take a n of 16
that's a nice healthy n let's take an n
of 25 and let's compare them a little
bit
let's compare them a little bit
so if we let's just do the i'll do one
trial animated just
it's always nice to see it so first it's
going to do 16 of these trials and
average them and there we go and it's
going to do 25 of these trials
and then average them
and then there we go now let's do that
what i just did animated let's do it 10
000 times
miracles of computers now notice
something this is 10 000 times these are
both pretty good approximations of
normal distributions the n is equal to
25 is more normal it has less skew
slightly less q than n is equal to 16.
it has slightly less kurtosis which
means it's it's it's it's closer to
being a normal distribution than n is
equal to 16. but even more interesting
it's more squeezed in it has a lower
standard deviation the standard
deviation here was 2 is 2.1 and the
standard deviation here is 2.64
so that's another i mean you know and i
i kind of touched on that in the last
video and it kind of makes sense for
every sample you do for your average the
more you put in that sample the less
standard deviation think of the extreme
case if instead of taking 16 samples
from our distribution every time or
instead of taking 25 if i were to take a
million samples from this distribution
every time if i were to take a million
samples from this distribution every
time that sample mean is always going to
be pretty darn close to my mean if i
take a million samples of everything if
i try to essentially try to estimate a
mean by taking a million samples i'm
going to get a pretty good estimate of
that mean the probability that it it you
know that a bunch of the a million
numbers are all out here is very low so
if i if n is a million of course all of
my sample all of my sample means when i
average them are all going to be really
tightly focused around the mean itself
and it actually and so you know
hopefully that that kind of
makes sense to you as well if it doesn't
you know just think about it or even use
this use this tool and experiment with
it just so you you can trust that that
is really the case and it actually turns
out that there's a very clean formula
that relates the standard deviation of
the original probability distribution
function to the standard deviation of
the sampling distribution of the sample
mean and as you can imagine it is a
function of your sample size of how many
samples you take out in every basket
before you average them and i'll go over
that in the next video